No longer the work of science-fiction, Artificial Intelligence introduces a new world and a new reality:
one in which machines would be trained to think for themselves.
From facial recognition and warehouse robots, to virtual assistants and autonomous vehicles,
the existence of humans and machines are starting to merge.
That's why the time has never been more important to consider how to create your ethical business framework for responsible AI development.
This is a chief requirement for any AI strategy,
and it is where we focus this course.
You will learn what is driving the adoption of AI and the need for ethical frameworks,
how to approach and build your company's framework,
and what open source software projects are supporting the ethical advancement of these technologies.